karl lauterbach der letzte
gesundheitsminister deutschlands der
noch verzweifelter an den sieg seines
viren krieges glaubt und das auf kosten
der bevölkerung dasselbe schauspiel dass
wir das sehen wir auch in österreich im
übrigen in den einzigen beiden ländern
europas wo noch verzweifelt windisch
präsidenten verehrt wird aber nicht
daran gedacht in wahrheit bereits buch
wie kann die situation für die menschen
für die bürgerinnen und bürger deren
gesundheit längst entspannter wie es
verlängern verzweifelt an den massnahmen
lauterbach versucht mit immer schärferen
worten auf richtung herbst eine eigene
existenzberechtigung aber auch die
seines virologischen knechts dr russen
recht zu fertigen das auch garniert mit
seiner ständigen forderung eine
impfpflicht durchzuführen wird aber
bereits von namhaften expertinnen und
experten im deutschsprachigen raum
selbst widersprochen doch bei ständigen
biologen anderes mit instruktoren von
love erst jüngst gemeint wird dass die
infektiosität zwischen diensten und
umgehend mittlerweile die selber ist das
heißt aber verheißungen und gelobte in
change zum kleinen raum ist sondern wie
gerade durchs mikro sehen könnten dass
wir uns noch alle geht längst
zurücktreten zeugen was wir derzeit
sehen sind hohe infektionen ihrer
keinerlei auswirkungen auf die
volkswirtschaft und auf die gesundheit
der bevölkerung hat intensivstationen
sind die oder weniger leer in um eine
bettenstation sind leer wir sehen aber
eine angespannte situation durch
infektionen und daher wäre es das maß
aller dinge nun endlich mit den
maßnahmen quarantänebestimmungen masken
pflicht aber auch mit endlich
aufzuräumen
ja ich bin glaube ich mit meinem
vorredner nicht immer einer meinung aber
hier wirklich nur beipflichten
also ich sehe ich auch so etwas
speziellen perspektive wenn ich habe ja
zehn jahre in china gelebt und was man
wirklich sagen muss also dieser ganze
lockdown wahnsinnig meine der finger an
in china in brand und wurde dann in
abgeschwächter form in der ganzen welt
übernommen also eigentlich das konzept
eines totalitären staates von dem man
sagen muss jetzt im nachhinein dass es
den ja nicht mal was gebracht hat ich
mein china hat es zwar geschafft mit
diesem knallharten maßnahmen jetzt für
eine längere zeit für zwei jahre die
zahlen relativ niedrig zu halten auf
kosten dass sie das land völlig von der
außenwelt abgeschlossen haben quasi
niemand mehr in das land reisen oder nur
noch mit drei wochen in quarantäne und
auch da nur wenige ausgewählte leute so
und jetzt sieht man in diesen tagen dass
es ihnen nichts nutzt weil das ergebnis
dieser 0 wird politik hier bei uns auch
einige propagiert haben ist dass die
leute nicht immun sind jetzt hat man 1,4
milliarden chinesen von dem nur paar
tausend überhaupt die krankheit gehabt
haben und das ist jetzt eine katastrophe
für china und die sind jetzt im dilemma
muss nicht mehr rauskommen also das
einzige ist das land für immer zusperren
und immer ganze städte in zwangs
quarantäne und zwangs testungen zu
schicken also ein ein völliger irrsinn
und als er ja noch ein unterschied ob
man jetzt sagt man macht das wie in
china schlechter werden ganze städte ja
tatsächlich tage oder sogar wochen lang
abgeriegelt und kaum einer kann aus der
eigenen haustür raus und das gilt ja
wirklich für millionen menschen oder ob
ich sage beim einkaufen ziehe ich doch
die maske auf da finde ich sollte man
schon differenzieren ich finde auch dass
einige maßnahmen nicht mehr zeitgemäß
sind und dass man die auch auslaufen
lassen sollte beziehungsweise abschaffen
sollte aber zum beispiel die masken
pflicht beim einkaufen halte ich für
sinnvoll weil das ein relativ
niedrigschwelliger eingriff ist also das
ist für die meisten jetzt nicht
besonders schlimm und gleichzeitig sorgt
aber so eine maske dafür dass sich das
virus nicht ausbreitet und wir haben ja
schon in vielen krankenhäusern zum glück
nicht mehr eine belastung der
intensivstation aber auf die
normalstation
und wir haben auch sehr viele ärzte und
pflegekräfte die im moment corona
bedingt ausfallen das heißt auf ihren
stationen in deutschlands krankenhäusern
sind da im moment zu wenig ärzte auch
weil sich corona immer noch zu stark
verbreitet und deswegen sollte man
differenzieren also es gibt ja ein
mittelweg zwischen der ganz harten
chinesischen variante und der variante
alles herbst die einrichtungs bezogen im
schlecht für die ich war immer dafür
dass wir gesagt also ich habe dafür
gestimmt ja weil ich gesagt habe wenn
ärzte und pflegekräfte am patienten
arbeiten oder mit der so genannten
variablen gruppen das heißt personen die
wirklich häufig auch besonders gefährdet
sind dann finde ich ist es richtig dass
die ärzte und pflegekräfte auch geimpft
sind das ist einmal schutz für die
patienten aber natürlich sind die auch
in einer einrichtung tätig die besonders
sensibel ist deswegen habe ich im
bundestag dafür gestimmt bei der
allgemeinen pflicht wäre ich dafür wenn
sichergestellt wird der impfstoff wirkt
und wir können weitere lockdown im
herbst und winter vermeiden weil ich da
sagen würde in der abwägung ist die
impfpflicht ein geringerer eingriff was
wir auf jeden fall vermeiden müssen sind
weitere lockdown und sind weitere grund
und frites einschränkungen im nächsten
herbst und winter
bevor jetzt die allgemeine bevor jetzt
die allgemeine hysterie wieder
ausbrechen wir diskutieren glaube ich
schon über diesen sogenannten corona
virus der zuletzt auffällig durch die
mikro mutation wurde der eine letalität
von nur 0,1 prozent hat also eine
sterblichkeit von 0,1 ich gehe schon
davon aus bevor aufgehört und der bloß
schon wieder locker sowie eine
impfpflicht sogar in erwägung zieht dass
man lockt das war ihnen dann kann das
wir jetzt nicht von ebola sprechen also
es wird nicht 50 prozent unserer
population die haxen weg räumen wie wir
in österreich soll schon sagen sondern
es handelt sich um eine erkrankung die
ähnlich einer saisonalen influenza nun
auftritt aber dann ersuche ich doch
endlich die logik und die vernunft
walten zu lassen wie man mit einer
influenza umgeht bis vor zwei jahren
habe es doch keinen menschen
interessiert ob mein nachbar eine
saisonale grippe hatte und einen
schnupfen wie er sie warschauer auch
gern oder bloß ist in den magen wie ich
auch so bleiben wenn sie eine krippe
haben meistens unter einer fast
tödlichen erkrankung aber das kann er
nicht dazu führen nur weil wir den
männer schnupfen haben dass wir einmal
mehr schon jetzt wieder die
argumentation liefern das gesamte volk
in einem look also schicken mit einer
sinn oder nutzlosen in pflicht zu
behandeln oder in einer freiheits- und
grundrechte zu raum der virus ist ein
fliegenschiss und 21 statistischer
fliegenschiss sowie viele andere
millionen von erkrankungen ist der
menschheitsgeschichte auch gegeben hat
und daher appelliere ich endlich auch
nicht mehr über dieses kann ohne zu
diskutieren wie wir auch nicht über die
grid betonten diskutiert haben wie wir
auch nicht über die
lungenentzündungen ehrlich diskutieren
über die herzinfarkte auch nicht
diskutieren ja ich habe also den man
vielleicht was dazu sagen darf ich finde
durchaus ich teile die meinung das ist
jetzt irgendwann mal schluss sein muss
man kann beobachten dass omikron harmlos
ist an sich selber und an anderen die
quarantänevorschriften sind so dass wir
unsere volkswirtschaft einen
schaden zufügen der eigentlich nicht
mehr im verhältnis steht ich würde nur
sehr dafür plädieren dass wir denjenigen
die uns durch diese corona krise
gebracht haben jetzt nicht jede
kompetenz absprechen es mag sein dass
ihnen vielleicht jetzt da ausstieg
schwer fällt und ich hoffe dass sie
gründe dafür haben ich finde wir können
uns jetzt zu wort melden und sagen jetzt
ist es genug und es gibt ja auch
genügend wissenschaftler die diese
auffassung bestätigte stöhr ein virologe
war heute hier wieder geschieht zum
beispiel den auch dafür plädiert das ist
jetzt genannt aber sein lässt ja aber
ich finde wir dürfen deshalb nicht so
den stab brechen ich verstehe dass man
das als österreicher besonders gut kann
aber ich würde doch ein bisschen respekt
für das was die die letzten zwei jahre
gemacht haben dafür würde ich plädieren
gut aber die frage ist ja an sich weiter
geht und noch einmal zu herrn + ich mein
ich habe nichts dagegen dass jemand eine
maske ansieht nur ich denke wir haben
jetzt so viele erfahrungen mit dieser
pandemie dass wir so machen können
bisher die anderen europäischen länder
auch machen wenn der maske ansehen will
soll das machten aber in ihren reihen
sich gerade wieder davon verabschiedet
die haben ja auch gesagt naja masken
pflicht damit beenden wir dann machen
wir nahe dran die gibt es nicht mehr und
jetzt haben vor kurzem die österreicher
die wieder eingeführt haben aber das
video bilder ist aber frau schenkt das
ist doch der belang ist das der beleg
dafür dass das nicht so sinnvoll weil
sonst hätten die österreicher doch nicht
gesagt wir führen die masten pflicht
wieder ein weil die gesehen haben weil
sie gesehen haben das virus verbreitet
sich dadurch relativ schnell und es gibt
einen wichtigen punkt den man schon
beachten muss und deswegen corona schon
ein unterschied ist noch zu anderen
krankheiten oder auch nicht immer
vergleichbar ist mit anderen viren krone
hat ja dazu geführt dass die
krankenhäuser und vor allem die
intensivstationen relativ schnell
vollgelaufen sind dass die ärzte und
pflegekräfte an ihre grenzen das war
wohl auch
stationäre ganz so war das nicht also so
eine situation hatten wir in der form in
vielen krankenhäusern in ganz
deutschland seit vielen jahrzehnten
nicht mehr so deswegen ist aber ja schon
was anderes los dass das ist das ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt war wenn man jetzt
sagt ist er gar keine maßnahmen ergeben
auch keine masten pflicht dann nimmt man
möglicherweise in kauf dass die
normalstation oder die intensivstation
überlaufen sind dass operationen
verschoben werden müssen und das muss
man dann den menschen auch ehrlich sagen
und das möchte ich persönlich nicht und
deswegen will ich dafür maßnahmen wie
eine maske trägt beim einkaufen
beizubehalten aber sinnlose maßnahmen
aufzugeben und auch den weg in richtung
normalität wieder angelassen nochmal
unseren österreichischen exportschlager
zu wollen kam herr gross ich merke schon
sie wollen jetzt auch direkt darauf
reagieren möchten haben abgehört und
bloßen einen guten tipp gemischt was
selbst nationalratsabgeordneter er sich
nicht von der dummheit der österreicher
anstecken lassen einzig echten
exportschlager den wir derzeit haben ist
es die gleichen inhalt und blödheit
unserer regierung und welche ware die
sogenannte masken pflicht in österreich
angesprochen wann ist ich möchte jetzt
in meinem eigenen wohnt sind man maske
tragen so sieht es die neue verordnung
aus wenn ich hingegen auf die straße
geht kann ich die maske abnehmen wenn
ich einen konzertsaal betrete mit
sitzplatz zuweisung kann ich eine maske
tragen wenn ich ein konzert besucher
ohne sitzplatz zuweisung frage ich keine
maske
gott sei dank wieder schnell in der
kleinheit der österreichischen regierung
kam ganze helden legenden vielen punkten
auch gehört schauen sie ich muss davon
sind da durchaus recht geben wir jammern
seit 20 jahren herum dass wir unser
gesundheitssystem
optimieren wir haben es optimiert wir
haben zu tode optimiert wie im
großgeräte abgeschafft weil es sich die
kassen nicht leicht wir haben
operationen geburtenstation zu gesperrt
weil wir gesagt haben sind zu wenig
geburten belohnt sich der umsatz nicht
das heißt wir haben in jedem ort vulgo
hinter scheiß klappenbach einen
kreisverkehr begründet und den
oberbürgermeistern es mit einem
gewünschten dort gestanden hat sich
gefreut aber im gleichen ort haben wir
das spital gesperrt wir haben ein zu
tode gespart ist gesundheitssystem und
das sehen wir auch jetzt bei den hohen
infektionszahlen des pflegepersonals und
des medizinischen personals also sie ist
wieder kein grund der sich ursächlich
auf das virus zurückführen lässt sondern
auch wenn gesundheitssystem das
wahrscheinlich ist vernachlässigt haben
und wenn ich die deutsche
bundesregierung gesichert wir haben doch
da muss ich mir einiges spital eröffnen
dort aber 100 milliarden dürfen gerne
rheinhessen hat sagt ich da muss ich da
muss ich jetzt sofort daran gehindert
bei ihrem blut fließen da muss ich jetzt
da muss ich jetzt mal sofort reingehen
weil erst mal ist es ja nicht so dass
jetzt eine million ärzte und eine
million pflegekräfte in deutschland oder
auch in österreich zur verfügung ständen
und man müsste die einfach nur etwas
besser bezahlen dann werden die alle da
und alle probleme werden gelöst und wenn
sie sich mal auch in der welt umschauen
dann sehen sie doch dass alle länder der
welt mit diesem problem massiv zu
kämpfen hatten das war doch nicht so
dass wir jetzt hier so ein deutschen
oder österreichischen sonderweg gegangen
sind und deswegen war nicht auch davor
dass man jetzt sagt das alles völlig
harmlos und wir können sofort auch alles
aufgeben was wir in der vergangenheit
gemacht haben und reden dass jetzt auch
noch alles schlecht wir sind ja in
deutschland auch in österreich im
vergleich zu vielen ländern relativ gut
durch die krise gekommen
dafür muss man auch einmal sagen und
deswegen schwefe rentieren liegen ja ich
bin ja genau ich bin ja genau bei ihnen
dass man seit den chinesischen weg den
wollen wir ja gar nicht gehen wir wollen
jetzt sich eine stadt wie berlin ja
abriegeln und sagen keiner kann mehr vor
die haustür gehen aber warum ist es dem
berliner nicht zumutbar dass er beim
einkaufen kurz einmal die maske rausholt
die dann auf setzt seine einkäufe
erledigt und die dann wieder absetzt
also es war nicht die maske nicht das
hauptproblem hauptproblem finde ich im
moment zum beispiel die quarantäne
regeln das ganze bereiche lahmgelegt
werden von leuten die
angeblichen krankheit haben sie aber
keine symptome haben also bisher war für
mich jemand am maßstab wenn die
krankheit man hat symptome aber die nur
weil sie offen an test einen positiven
test haben und ansonsten völlig gesund
sind und auf der grundlage das ganze
leben lahm zu legen das kann denke ich
auf dauer nicht gehen ich finde die
baskets auch nicht das größte problem
das hätte ich im zug auch eine masse an
aber man sieht ja bei den dänen überall
bei den schweden dass sie auch sehr gut
und die maske auskommen und vor allem
denke ich ich gebe ihnen auch recht
etwas anfangen corona neue krankheit man
wusste nicht wie damit umgehen aber
jetzt kennen wir uns damit aus jetzt
wissen wir wie die omikron variante
wirkt und jetzt finde ich muss ist zeit
zur eigenverantwortung zurückzukehren
das ist eine maske will kann sie
anziehen